what's up Wolfgang we have some updates
on the Captain Marvel trailer and the
Avengers 4 trailer and title as well
there has been a lot of Avengers 4 title
theories about when the release is gonna
happen when it's gonna be revealed to us
when we're gonna get the first trailer
and a lot of these theories actually
thought that in the post-credits scenes
of ant-man and the wasp that is when
they're gonna tell us the title well got
some bad news
the president of Marvel Kevin Feige
himself came out and publicly stated
that this is not going to happen when
asked about the title reveal for
Avengers 4 this is what he had to say
that'll be after the Captain Marvel
teaser probably announcing that title
it'll be towards the end of the year
with however we launched that film now
as far as Captain Marvel is concerned we
have yet to receive anything official
from Marvel Studios regarding the movie
and again Marvel President Kevin Feige
was asked about this and here's what he
had to say in regards to Captain Marvel
you already know as much as you need to
we've got Scrolls we've got the Kree it
takes place in the 90s you have Sam
Jackson with two eyes and Carol Danvers
a unique telling of Carol Danvers origin
story we are about two weeks out from
completion of principal photography so
since they are about two weeks away from
completion of the principal photography
this means that we probably have a few
months at least until we received the
official trailer for Captain Marvel and
this makes sense because Captain Marvel
doesn't come out until next year in
March and Avengers 4 doesn't come out
until after that so unfortunately it
seems like we are still a bit away from
receiving a trailer for Captain Marvel
and an official title for Avengers 4 now
of course Kevin Feige could be trolling
us and we could actually see the reveal
for Avengers 4 in the post-credits
scenes of him and the wasp but I really
doubt it
they pulled some tricks for Avengers
infinity war but I don't see them doing
this for Avengers 4 at least not with
the title so there you have it there's
an update on when we're going to receive
the trailer for Captain Marvel and when
we are going to receive the official
title and trailer for Avengers
for let me know what you all think the
title for Avengers 4 is going to be in
the comments below I'm curious to read
them as always be sure to LIKE this
video if you enjoyed it and don't forget
to subscribe to stay up to date on
Captain Marvel Avengers for all things
Marvel DC and superhero thank you so
much for watching woof woof
you